As we go to our next game,
Chemistry Experiments.
You know, one of the...
one of the weirdest parts
of any award shows
is the bizarre pairings
of the celebrity presenters.
For-for example, last night
at the Golden Globes,
which somehow was convinced
that The Martian is a comedy.
It's not really a comedy,
but (bleep) it, we got
Matt Damon on the show.
Uh, they forced Ricky Gervais
and Mel Gibson
to share the stage, I guess
'cause of their mutual interest
in public intoxication.
Needless to say, these two
had worse chemistries than
a Me-Mexican meth lab, so...
If that wasn't awkward enough,
they also had Magic Mike present
with the bear
who raped Leonardo DiCaprio.
So comedians,
as an award show announcer,
I would like you
to announce weirder couplings
who should give awards
at the next Golden Globes
in 60 seconds, and begin.
Jackie.
Uh, please welcome
Sean Penn and El Chapo.
All right, points.
That's real,
that really happened!
Pete Holmes.
Please welcome,
from Tony! Toni! Toné!,
Tony and Toni.
Toné couldn't make it.
Points. Genius.
Thank you for making
a Tony! Toni! Toné! reference.
See, they all spell
the "Tony" differently,
that's how it works.
Points. Jackie.
Uh, please welcome Donald Trump
and a copy of the Koran.
Points.
Brett.
Please welcome Bill Cosby
and his wife Camille.
All right, points.
Pete Holmes.
Please welcome Paula Deen
and DMX.
Yeah. Points. Pete Holmes.
Please welcome Chris Hardwick
and a BB-8 that he's (bleep).
-Yes! So, BB-8.
-(buzzer sounds)
I could get that.
I could totally get that.
-Huh. A moment.
-♪ I'm waiting -You know,
sometimes you just... you just
got a chemistry with someone.
-You know? I'm... What?
-WOMAN: Oh, my God.
Somebody's really getting off
on you (bleep) a BB-8 out there.
Oh, sorry,
that's also a spoiler.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
It's, uh...
uh... BB-8 out, uh, by me.
-By me.
-Oh, nice.